So part of figuring out how to solve word
problems well is figuring out what
information isn't important for the
question that we're trying to answer. We
want to know how much money Grant's going
to make from selling nozzles. All that
this is going to depend on is the price
per nozzle and how many people want to buy
nozzles. That means that these answers
with 36, which has to do with the people
who want to buy wipers are irrelevant for
this question. Also w is the price per
wiper set not per nozzle, so this answer
which depends on w can't be correct. And
this one even though it also involves an
n, involves a w so, it can't be right
either. We're only focusing on nozzle
sales here. So what are we left with 11,
11 times 2 and 22 and 11n. Well, this looks
pretty good nothing having to do
explicitly with wiper sales. However,
these 2 answers 11 and 22 don't involve an
n. That will mean that no amount or how
many nozles Grant sells, he's going to
make either just $11 or $22. I would hope
that, for his sake, the more nozzles he
sells, the more money he makes so we want
to say that those answers aren't correct.
So now we have 11 times 2n and 11n. The key here
is remembering that each of these eleven
people want two nozzles. Not just one
nozzle. So each person who buys two
nozzles is going to pay him not n dollars
but 2n dollars. If 11 people paying 2n
dollars so that means we need 11 times 2n which
is this answer right here.